- Welcome to the show (laughs).
Well, this morning I was
thinking about our guest today,
Gwyneth Paltrow, and I am so excited
to talk to her about co-parenting.
And I've learned one of the
most important life lessons
for my tiny existence
which is I cannot control things.
Because so much of the time,
you know, I just don't
get that luxury of things
being exactly the way
I would like them to be
and I have learned that it
is my reaction I can control.
And we're gonna talk about
it when you have to co-parent
and figuring that out,
not only is it an art but
it is within our control
of how we deal with it with our kids.
And all I ever wanna do
is make my kids feel safe.
And again, we can't control everything
but we can have a true part
in how I conduct myself
within our family.
And I can't wait to talk about it
because it's such a big part of my world
and my kids really are my priority.
Another thing I couldn't
control this weekend
was I took Frankie to the aquarium
and we drove an hour
and we watched the river
out our car windows and I
hugged the curves in my minivan,
through the lanes like I
was coloring in a book.
It was Sunday.
And when we finally got there,
unfortunately I didn't know
you had to make reservations
and we were not able to get
in because rules are rules.
And that's the lesson I
tried to teach Frankie.
I certainly didn't wanna
teach her the wrong thing
in that moment.
But then, of course, I asked the lady
if I gave her some cash
could she look the other way.
(audience laughs)
And she said, "Ma'am, you
can make reservations online
"and book your tickets,"
with an unmovable tone.
And I said, "Oh, God, please no.
"I'm not a payer offer normally,
"I just thought since you
were closing soon anyway
"and I just think your
bosses should actually know
"what an amazing person you are
"that you will simply
not break the rules."
(audience laughs)
But then I was curious,
has anyone else ever tried
to find a clever way in
when like the signs say,
"No entry," so to speak.
I love receiving a no after
I've tried everything.
And if you have a story, without
breaking the law of course,
if you do have one I wanna hear it, okay?
Have ya tried to figure out
how to get your kid into a sold
out aquarium type of thing?
Go to Twitter and send us your story
and use the hashtag,
hashtag rule bending parent.
So good news, Frankie learned that things
don't always go as planned
and things aren't always
within our control
and we went to Nathan's Hotdogs
and I found one open carnival game
and we played all the money
that woman wouldn't take.
And good for her.
And we drove home happy and life was good.
And when you know your
kids are truly happy,
not because they got what they wanted
but because Plan B was just as good, well,
that was my morning share.
And now let's get into some
important and awesome things
taking place in and around our world.
It's time for Drew's News.
(audience cheers and applauds)
(car squealing)
(cat meowing)
(upbeat dramatic music)
Sir! Ma'am! Guy!
Ma'am, I asked you a question.
Tell me your story!
It's Drew's News.
(audience cheers and applauds)
Do you ever feel overwhelmed
by the tidal wave of news out there?
Well, relax. We've got you covered.
We sift through it all
to find a few nuggets
to start your day.
And here we go.
Let's see what made the papers.
(audience applauds)
(Drew clears through loudly)
Excuse me, frog in throat. Hang on.
(clears throat loudly)
Ahh.
The Detroit news is reporting something
that sparked my interest.
Lego is going to swap
out its plastic packaging
in favor of paper packaging!
(audience applauds)
And all because kids demanded it.
However, Lego pieces are
still incredibly painful
to step on and maybe they
can work on that next.
(audience laughs)
These kids make me feel so optimistic.
I mean, Lego is a huge brand.
This will have a giant impact.
Reducing plastic is so important.
My friend, Cameron Diaz,
I'm not name-dropping,
she just happens to be my friend.
(audience laughs)
She used to get on me
for the last 20 years,
she was so ahead of the curve.
You know, she's always been
environmentally conscious
and she used to turn off all my lights
and my pool heater
and tell me to go get a
hybrid car, and you know?
I finally, I switched.
I made her a promise a year ago
and I drink out of these
paper water companies
which they show that the
packaging is possible
and they taste delicious.
I really love them.
And I have this metal cup that's missing.
I'll show you later.
And I used to drink out of styrofoam
so like this is a big deal for me.
And I'm one small person,
I don't think I can make a big change.
And when I see something
like Lego is doing this
then I think change is possible.
And if we all continue to be
mindful about these things,
we can change our world for our kids.
But again, parents, when you're screaming
after stepping on one of those Legos.
Ahh!
(audience laughs)
That's okay too.
So moving on.
(audience applauds)
Our next story.
'Cause that's what happens
when you step on a Lego. Ahh!
This story warmed my heart.
In a radio interview the other day,
Usher shared this story behind
his latest single, "I Cry."
And he's quoted as saying that
he didn't have a
relationship with his father.
And so when he was watching a
movie with his two young sons
and there was an emotional
father/son moment on screen,
he started to cry.
And then his sons were
shocked and they asked him,
"Are you crying, Dad?"
And he said that he
took that moment to say,
"Yeah, I am crying," and that it was okay.
And a song was born.
Thank you, Usher.
We should be teaching boys
that it's okay to cry at an early age.
And he says that empathy can
bring us all closer together,
incredibly difficult
times such as we're in,
and I couldn't agree more.
So it turns out, men are
crying now more than ever.
Welcome to the club.
(upbeat dance music)